[موسيقى]
حمله انتخابيه ماراثونيه تلك التي يقودها
الرئيس اردوغان قبيل انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه توصف بانها الاصعب في تاريخ
حزبه
حمله تركز بشكل كبير على وعود باعاده بناء
المدن التي ضربها زلزال كهرمان مراش
وبمرحله من التنميه المستدامه والانتعاش
الاقتصادي نحلم بمئويه تركيا ويحلمون
بتركيا المهمشه القديمه بسياستها المجزئه
واقتصادها الهش
وديمقراطيتها الضعيفه
[موسيقى]
في شوارع المدن التركيه تنتشر كوادر حزب
العداله والتنميه ومرشحوه للبرلمان لشرح
البرامج المستقبليه وتذكير الناس
بالمشاريع الضخمه التي انجزها الحزب ليس
لدينا شك في اننا سنفوز الشعب يعرف ما
الذي قدمه الرئيس لهذه الامه خلال 21 عاما
لكن المعارضه تقول انها ستفوز لانكم
تتحدثون عن المشاريع العملاقه بينما الناس
يعانون من الغلاء
نعم هناك ازمه اقتصاديه لكنها عالميه
واقتصادنا يعمل بكفاءه وهذا سينعكس على
المواطن قريبا المواطنون يعرفون ان
اردوغان وحده هو الذي يمكنه تجاوزه هذه
الازمه
لا تنظر الى هذه الانتخابات على انها فرصه
تاريخيه للفوز
زعيم وحزب الشعب الجمهوري يخوض المنافسه
ضمن تحالف واسع علماني يساري وقومي ومحافظ
ويعد بتغيير ما يصفه بحكم الفرد وبانقاذ
البلاد من الازمه الاقتصاديه
هذه هي الانتخابات التي سيعاد فيها بناء
الديمقراطيه وبناء تركيا التي لن ينام
فيها طفل وهو جائع
رافقنا اوز المرشح للبرلمان الحزب الشعبي
الجمهوري في جولته اليوميه على المحل
التجاريه في مختلف مناطق اسطنبول
نشرح للتجار حقيقه الوضع الاقتصادي ونتحدث
لهم عن خطه حزبنا لانقاذ البلاد ماذا
اخبروكم وعلى ماذا تعتمدون بالاساس للخروج
من الازمه
التجار مهمومون يتحدثون لنا عن ارتفاع
الاسعار وانخفاض القدره الشرائيه خطه نابل
اساس تعتمد على التشاركيه في الحكم
وبعد انسحاب محرم جاء من السباق الانتخابي
وهو المحسوب على اليسار التركي بقي سنان
القومي الذي يركز برنامجه الانتخابي بشكل
اساسي على ضروره اعاده اللاجئين السوريين
الى بلادهم
ربما كثير من الناس مقتنعون بالرجلين لكن
معظمهم لن يصوتوا لهما لاعتقادهم ان
اصواتهم ستذهب سدى في ظل التنافس الكبير
بين تحالفي الشعب والجمهور كل حي او شارع
في تركيا قد يكونوا ساحه للتنافس الحاد
على استقطاب المواطنين قبيله اقتراع يوصف
بانه الاكثر تعقيدا في تاريخ بلد طالما
صاحبه المنافسه السياسيه بين احزابه حاله
من الاستقطاب الشديد والمزمن
عمر لا في الجزيره اسطنبول